all right we're life I think everybody's
doing okay you might know if you can see
it on my face but I've been really ill
in the past few days so hopefully this
will go okay I might have to sneeze or I
might sniffle a little bit during this
but a few days ago I just slept all day
I was so horribly ill all right so few
announcements before we start first of
all I want to really thank the people
that are running the clips Channel I
think everybody has to check it out it's
pretty amazing they've been putting out
a video every day I think and just
trying to get little nuggets out of my
videos it's been great they're gonna put
up a Christmas list a Christmas playlist
I think it's coming out on December 20th
and trying to pull out different things
that I've said about Christmas during
during the year so check that out don't
forget to subscribe to the cliff's
Channel
I think they have a lot in store for us
in the next few months so so yeah a few
a few things that are pretty sure now
are gonna happen I am definitely going
to be in Seattle in May I'll be giving a
a carving workshop and also a conference
so I'm gonna be there for like a whole
week I'm also going to be near Boston in
June giving another carving workshop and
probably giving some talks I will be in
Saskatoon in January mid-january giving
also a carving workshop but I think that
carving workshop is are is closed but
I'll also be giving a one or two talks
during that week so stay tuned I will
post the dates and the places either on
the videos or check out my website as I
get the final details I will always post
the events there so so that's that's
been going on so let's go let's just
start because there are a lot of
questions I think that I might I want to
warn everybody that I might I might if I
see that people are posting several
questions I might just take one of your
questions because
now there they're just too many
questions coming on so I would suggest
that people try to that people try to to
really get one question in a month for
the for the people who put the questions
at in advance we'll see I'll try to do
what I can I'll try to answer all the
questions but I'm not sure I'll be able
to answer all the questions oh I have a
question is who's there in are there any
of the moderators in the chat I see that
Jonathan Jonathan Jonathan Pedro clips
is in the chat who's in the chat is is
Kristian Chad there I know that Jacob is
not there hmm
Vivek varna sarandí says I'm a deputy
moderator do I know you've evac I'm not
sure I know you
let's see I need a moderator if I have
no moderator or Elsa this is gonna get
bad who's there who's there that I know
in the chat is there anybody that I know
I'm like I'm gonna put whoever it is
this that's whoever it is that's coming
here as my cliffs channel if it's Lisa
or if it's a Pete I'm going to I'm
adding you as a moderator hopefully it's
somebody I know Lisa's there I'm putting
as a moderator anyways Lisa just in case
all right hopefully that'll be good
enough if not it's gonna get if not it's
gonna get it's gonna get nuts there it's
gonna get nuts in them in the in the
Mott in the moderate we'll see anyways
whatever alright let's go let's go let's
just do this and and if I see at least
this is how does one moderate I don't
know at least I've never done it myself
I've just I've just always added other
people as moderator alright let's just
go let's do this and if we get crazy
people trying to fill the chat with
nonsense I'll just I'll just name random
moderators hopefully that they'll do
okay
all right here we go okay so I'm
starting with V with my website as you
know people who give at at ten dollars
or more they have a chance to ask
questions in advance and so I'm gonna go
from my website to subscribe SAR and
finally to patreon alright here we go so
david Flores asks in aristocracy is
aristocracy kings queens etc another
marginal figure the thought occurred to
me when when listening to you and
Benjamin Boyce talk about elites having
trouble relating to common people no I
don't think that you have to understand
them as marginal figures the one thing
you do have to understand that there's a
relationship between the summit of
something and the margin there's a
there's a relationship between the
beginning and the end and actually
they're not the same they're opposites
and so there's there's a relationship
between the king and the popper you see
that in stories you know the idea that
the king in the popper trade place you
see it in stories where the the prince
will marry a a peasant girl you see this
idea that there is somehow a
relationship between the lowest and the
highest and it has to do with I have to
do with the flip that happens at the
lowest point and then flip there's also
has to do with a kind of mirror
reflection between the lowest and the
highest but it's important to understand
that no in a way they're opposites like
the the aristocracy is the aristocracy
is similar to the margin in in its when
what it looks like because usually the
aristocracy is a mixture you know the
Kings will marry foreign queens will the
Queen's will marry foreign kings in
order to create alliances and so the
kings what happens in the aristocracy is
that they actually are not the same as
the people there they're kind of like a
mix of different aristocracies and so in
that way just like the margin the
aristocracy has a kind of weird mixture
but it's it's in a way the opposite of
mixture because it's the joining
together
different things into into a point where
they can they can be in communion rather
than the place where there's a kind of
dispersion and a kind of fragmentation
on the edge so in a way they're
opposites but in a way one can kind of
become the other in certain terms and
ultimately that is why Christ relates
them together and said that he is the
beginning and the end he's the Alpha the
Omega that somehow he is able to join
the two extremes you would say together
so I hope that makes sense all right but
you can see it there's a lot of
symbolism like that there's a canoe you
know famously pointed out that there's
some interesting etymological
relationship between things like in
English for example like the idea of a
cap and a cape that it's actually come
from the same the same symbolism that
there's a relationship between horns in
terms of even fingernails and a crown of
a king I kind of talked about this this
strange symbolism of the extreme in in
some of my videos but that's as close as
it's gonna get but it's important even
though there are there are analogies and
there are ways in which they kind of
mirror each other it's important to not
confuse them and that's the problem
sometimes is that people will confuse
the beginning in the end the beginning
in the end are not the same they're the
diametrical opposites one can flip into
the other but they're not the same and
it's important to see the difference I
hope that makes sense all right here we
go so so mathesar asks hello I'm trying
to better understand earth in the
context of the non-dualistic view of the
Orthodox Church while rejecting both the
hard material this viewpoint and
nihilistic illusion in Maya in an essay
on mysticism in Eastern Church Nikolai
Villa Mir which says the nature of this
is a symbol of truth that the physical
universe is the visible parable of the
spiritual world the first is a symbol
the second is spirit and reality as far
as far as I understand the earth is the
means or letter of how spirit or meaning
may manifest similar to how markings
make up a letter that combined into
words to convey meaning yeah the letter
is real and necessary but only as a
reflection in how it conveys meaning but
what is the importance of the letter
after the meaning has been conveyed I'm
not sure what your question is where bro
okay markings without organization and
agreement are meaningless but it seems
arbitrary on the human level it it may
be arbitrary but the physical universe
does not seem arbitrary it has been
organized as a reflection of true
reality but in the end we are given a
new body with the new heaven and new
earth does this mean there will be new
meaning or a new reality that is more
true than this one or one that is better
than true how do we not reject this body
and physical reality for the better
cosmos to come thanks for everything you
do and for helping me put me on the
Orthodox path all right so I think your
question kind of boils down to the
problem of on the one hand realizing
that that we have this body of death
that we have we live in a world of
fragmentation of decomposition
you know the idea of the world of the
fall but at the same time we also have
the sense that everything has to
necessarily somehow contain the spark of
the divine in order for it to exist so
how do we reconcile those two things
together and so this image as you said
of the new body of the transform value
the transfigured body is the way that in
imagistic terms is given in the church
enniaa that we are resurrected in christ
that we have a that we can participate
in the resurrection now and also in the
eschaton and the ultimate moment when
everything comes together but the way to
kind of understand it is to understand
that the problem is not the problem the
thing that makes everything become that
makes everything look dark and
decomposed and the way that we
participated it is in it it's kind of
decomposed fragmented way or arbitrary
way is is because we are not looking in
the right direction
the sense that you get in the Mystics
and the sense that you get in the
father's is that if you actually detach
yourself from physical reality from from
your physical body let's say then you
will ultimately discover that it is
participating in the glory of God right
and so asceticism is not so much seeing
that the world is evil but it is trying
to remove your passions from all those
things trying to not be attached to all
the all these things around us in a
disordered way so that they will
actually appear ultimately as full of
life and glowing and so that seems to me
at least when I read some accidents that
seems to me to be what I see is that is
that we need to be able to remove
ourselves to a certain for a certain
time or for us to a certain amount from
let's say this kind of fallen broken
world not because it's evil in itself
but because as we remove ourselves from
it and we stop being attached to it
passionately then we can start to see
the the divine sparks that are hidden we
can start to see the world shine and
then it'll be it'll appear to us full of
glory
all right so believes one two three four
asks okay I've been reading brave new
world recently and in the book they
mentioned cutting the top of crosses to
make the letter T I know you have talked
about the horizontal and vertical coming
together to make a cross the horizontal
does not meet the vertical exactly in
the middle like a plus sign and it is
not all the way to the top like a tea it
is in between those places I wanted to
ask you what you thought the part above
the horizontal represented for my
understanding I believe that it is the
part of the Cross reserved to God that
is where the head would be if you are
crucified and in the Christian tradition
Christ is the head with Church with the
Church of his body
thank you for insight and for helping me
understand more then I thought was
possible this was just something I
thought was interesting so the way to
understand the cross is to understand
the vertical as the as the hierarchy
itself and so the hierarchy itself is
you could you con the one hand you could
call it heaven let's say but on the one
hand you could you could really
understand it as the different levels of
of this ontological hierarchy and the
the bar of the cross represents the
earth so the earth in the sense of a
level of of the hierarchy so each each
aspect of the world you know there's a
jump between each aspect of the world
right from your parts to your self from
ourselves to a nation let's say from the
nation or you know the best way to
understand is is from our gathering
together into the body of Christ to the
head of Christ so it's like every level
you could understand as this this these
levels of of the cross and so let's say
if you take the three barred cross for
example in the Orthodox faith you can
understand it as the three bars as
heaven earth and let's say the
underworld or the world of death so you
can have so when you have one bar it's
usually just represents the notion of
that level in the in the hierarchy but
the the vertical the axis itself is just
the actual string that holds everything
together that lets say the procession of
Logie the procession of essences that
are that are layered on top of each
other and descend from heaven down to
the bottom of the world you know I hope
that makes sense I feel like maybe I'm
I'm speaking too abstractly but I
struggled to find another way to explain
it um and so the idea of cutting the top
of the cross you know if you wanted to
make a cross it was just a tea would be
that you don't have the top part of the
hierarchy you just have the earth and
what is below until you kind of descend
into potentiality right and you don't
have access to the to the higher levels
of being to
to the to the principalities which are
above us and so it's a kind of so it's a
kind of a tea you could see it as a you
know as a kind of materialistic vision
of of reality you know and you could see
it as like in terms of brave new world
you could understand it as this idea of
let's say pleasure right so it's like
all the world the pleasure and all the
world of the passions or whatever
underneath and so you have the the world
and then everything down is what you are
with what your would they're attached to
in in brave new world
alright so Gabriel Malati says hi
Jonathan could you say something about
the symbolism of classical versus
baroque thank you
well I classical and Baroque art really
are really just two two poles of the of
modernism they're two poles of the
Enlightenment you know and they they're
they're just like a bouncing off of each
other and so in a way if you look at if
you look at traditional medieval
Christian architecture there's a there's
a kind of desire to create symmetry but
it's not absolute symmetry and that's
something that sometimes people don't
totally realize is that let's say in a
church there's a there's the basic
pattern of the cross and square or the
you know the dome on the square and or
the dome on a cross but you never get a
church that's just that there's the
pattern and then there's a kid there's a
desire to create variation so there's a
there's a kind of joining of a hierarchy
which is kind of hidden inside and then
there is a a freedom or a capacity to
improvise and to create variation and so
the idea ssin art is traditional
Christian art in terms of Byzantine art
or medieval art even up to the Gothic is
always a clay kind of balance between
those two now what happens in classical
art is you have a a pull towards this
iron fist of order right this this
capacity to to organize things extremely
powerful so you have high persimmon
trees and extremely centered buildings
that are that are that are so symmetric
that they almost feel dead and then the
Baroque goes in the other direction and
creates a kind of you know a kind of a
an opening up of improvisation to a
level that it's not I mean there's
levels right it's like I like Bach you
know it I'm fine with Bach but if you
imagine that Bach leads you know
something in Bach in terms of in terms
of breaking symmetry and in terms of
playing with symmetry and creating
disorder will lead you to Beethoven
let's say it's like you can see that
those two those two things are kind of
pulling against each other so then you
have you have classicism and Baroque and
then you have neoclassicism and
romanticism and you can see the same
pattern repeating itself then you see
and you see in modern art you have
formalism and abstract expressionism and
they're kind of pulling on each other
you have conceptual art and and and then
you have something like surrealism and
you have these these these poles that
are getting stronger and stronger in
terms of two extremes and so that's what
I think about that all right so Josh the
mover asks hello Jonathan
can you comment on Jesus uttering the
phrase Oh father why have you forsaken
me as he took his final breath I always
found this scene deeply unsettling my
first reaction when I thought about it
was that because Jesus said it believers
in him can no can no longer say it with
any authority before Christ I'm sure
many people felt as though God had
forsaken them from time to time but when
Jesus came knowing what he had to do and
because we humans are the ones who
killed him it now stands that anyone who
believed that Christ teaching cannot
truly say that God has forsaken them
anymore it seems like some kind of grand
flip obviously this is very complex but
I'm totally in the weeds where am I on
to something here thank you I all have
to be totally honest with you I have
never been satisfied with any of the
answers
that I have read to that question and
for all my love of the church fathers
and for all my love of the of the I am I
have felt like that phrase in Scripture
should just just remain in silence that
you can't understand that phrase because
it seems like it is the ultimate aporia
it seems like it really is the notion of
the logos emptying itself to its I don't
know I don't know I don't even know how
to say it I don't know how to say it all
I can say is that I am very grateful
that that mystery is there in Scripture
I think it's there to help us to know
that we don't understand everything and
that the the relationship between the
infinite being and non-being all of
these things are something that we can't
fully grasp and I think that when Christ
utters those words he is uttering one of
the most profound and disturbing and
difficult to understand mysteries that
have ever been uttered so and you know
it's tough for me when you guys ask me
to explain to you some of the things
that Jesus does because you know some of
the things that Jesus does are like
they're beyond meaning they're there
they're there creating the world and so
there and so yeah that's all I can say
about that but you can find the
traditional answer you can find usually
the traditional answer will read
something like that it was it was in a
way the human nature of Christ which was
expressing itself that kind of stuff you
see that in the father's you see that
kind of language but I I find that I
find that on
I find that it doesn't satisfy our
disturbance before that before that uh
before that statement so that's as much
as I'm gonna give you there all right so
SLS 94 asks dear Jonathan while reading
Genesis I encountered a passage that has
puzzled Vee yeah that I'm sure that's
gonna happen I was wondering if you
could share your thoughts about the
symbolism of Genesis 31 where Rachel
steals her father's idols hides them
under a camel saddle and seems to be
cursed by Jacob is there a connection
with Rachel's death in Genesis 35 wow so
you guys are you guys are all gonna
force me to talk about the symbolism of
menstruation I guess is what you guys
are gonna force me to talk about which
is not something that I intended to talk
about at least not anytime soon
and that's what it has to do with it has
it has to do with the symbolism of
menstruation you know a lot of stuff
that I tell you guys I am I don't
necessarily give you all the references
to where I get the things that I get
because some of the symbolism is
disturbing and so there's no point in
dwelling on that kind of stuff but the
the the when I talk about how the
ancient gods become like demons and they
become like residue from an ancient
civilization or residues of something
which is failed or failing right so so
you can imagine that Christianity
replaces Rome and the you know the old
were pagan Rome is is fallen it's a it's
a it's an a fallen state and the old
gods are demons and they and they are
they are our idols right um and that is
related to that's what the symbolism of
menstruation is about it has to do with
the idea of a failed union of heaven and
earth and so it's a it's a right so I
need to find when Rachel takes the idols
and put
them under her seat and and then they
they they I remember what it is they
want her to come and talk to I think
it's it's like her brother wants to come
see her to come see um to come see him
and she says I can't come to you because
I'm in my woman's ways and so you can
imagine she said she's having her period
and the idols are under her seat and so
the idols are stand-in for the four
menstruation that is a failed union of
heaven and earth a residue of an ancient
world she's not willing she's not
willing to leave the ancient world
behind she's not willing to she's
supposed to be leaving her brother and
joining in marriage with joining
relieving her father
sorry not her brother leaving her father
and joining him married with Jacob but
she wants to take she wants to take that
world with her but she has to leave it
behind it's no longer her world it's a
it's no longer the world in which
there's life she has to she has to leave
it behind just like just like you can
imagine menstruation as the preparing of
a body for the child and then there's no
seed which comes to make that body come
together no logos comes to the to that
body in order to in order to make it
whole to make it something and so it
falls apart and it disintegrates and you
have to let that go you have to you have
to get rid of it because it actually has
it's actually dangerous it has like it
has even infernal powers it has demonic
powers because it's these fragmented
pieces of things that aren't held
together and so that's what the old
idols all always are that's what the old
gods always end up being been to being
these fragmented crazy demons that that
that don't fit in the world anymore and
so the that's what that's what that
story is talking about that she had to
leave that behind because it was no
longer her body it was no longer the
body
that she was creating with her husband
but she didn't and so the gods
menstruation her not willing and her
taking her father's God's not leaving
them behind all of that has goes
together so yeah so I hope I hope that
makes sense
sorry if anybody of you are having
dinner or something but you guys forced
my arm on that one
alright so Diaz Bru asks Merry Christmas
Jonathan you mentioned that Christianity
is playing out its own narrative can you
lay this out a bit for us how do you
view the church east/west split and
subsequent fragmenting according to this
idea yeah I the when I when I mean when
I say that Christian is playing its own
narratives that I believe that that
Christianity the story of Christ is
happening at the at a global scale but
there are cycles of the story of Christ
you could say and so you can see that
this there's the story of Christ and
then there's the story of the church
before Rome which is like a cycle and
then you have the church kind of filling
up the world and then it's like a third
cycle so it's like it's so it's
different cycles of the same story at
different levels and I think that the
the church is also the church is also
going through the the story of itself
and so when you see it's not it would
you understand it that way than you
understand it's not surprising that
atheism would come out of Christianity
that Christianity would give birth to
atheism and that atheism would then
betray Christianity and then and then
Christianity would die or at least go
down into the into the pit and also go
go to the outside move to the outside
you know yeah it's like people don't
people don't don't see that it's that
how that that's happening you know so so
the Christ was a Jew
he came for the Jews and then the Jews
didn't accept him and so that went to
the Gentiles and Rome accepted him which
were the enemies of the Jews and then
Rome converts to Christianity you know
and then christians christians
evangelize the world and the world
doesn't at first doesn't really want but
you know doesn't necessarily want that
much to do with christianity and then
christian and then the Europe the
Europeans start to negate Christianity
start to refuse Christianity and betray
Christianity and then all of a sudden
you have you know millions and millions
of Christians more Christians in Africa
in Korea North South Korea in in China
now all over the world in South America
so and and so it's like Christianity as
it dies where its origin it it feeds the
next level and is growing and growing
and growing and that is playing itself
out in a way that I think is going to
cause a massive massive resurrection I
mean that's what the Bible says you know
I don't I can't totally tell you how
it's gonna happen but it seems like
that's the story that the Bible talks
about and and if you look at how history
has kind of played itself out it seems
to be seems to be what happened so let's
see how it does play itself out all
right so I'm done with the symbolic
world questions I'm gonna go in to
subscribe star alright so subscribe
sorry here we go Nicola asked Carl Jung
and Jordan Peterson will talk about
integrating the shadow is there a place
for this concept in Orthodox
Christianity the best I could come up
with is that we should be aware of our
own sinful desires so we could do
something about it
yeah I agree I'm I don't totally agree
with this idea of integrating the shadow
in the way that that young talks about
it I don't I don't totally see I think
it's a problem because it the idea that
that the shadow is something or that
darkness is something or that that
somehow these dark desires that you have
that they have an essence or they have a
body I think that that's definitely not
a Christian vision the Christian vision
is that the dark side your dark side
yeah obviously you have it it's there
and you have that in you you should deny
it in that sense you should integrate
your shadow in the sense that if you
pretend that you don't have that you're
you're in trouble
you have all these passions the the
Christian answer is to glorify them is
to is to to flip them to turn them and
have them facing up so that they
manifest their honorable the honorable
version of themselves and so so the the
closest as you said to the idea of
integrating the shadow is to be humble
and to see yourself as the as to see and
not deny all your darkness and to and to
let's say be willing to live up to
not to fess up to it and to not pretend
that you're better than other people but
to be able to see how dark you are not
in order to integrate it in the sense of
not in the sense of as if it's something
that you have to join with yourself in
order to become more but rather that you
have to be able to be fully aware of
yourself and know yourself so that you
can transform those dark desires into
something powerful and useful so maybe
that's what you means I don't know it
doesn't seem too
to be what you means but uh you know and
so the idea is no you know you all your
dark all your passions are are good
ultimately you just have to know how to
transform them to the grace of God of
course sorry gonna be sniveling into the
mic here it's kind of disgusting
alright so Charles Kincaid says I was
reading Dionysus is the divine names
that the beautiful is the same as the
good for everything looks to be to the
beautiful and the good as the cause of
being and that is the cause of harmony
and splendor and all things do you think
you could elaborate on that I've been
thinking a lot about the nature of
beauty and the scourge of ugliness we
find in modernity but I'm having
difficulty convincing people that it
isn't merely a matter of taste or vanity
yes I mean I totally agree of course and
you you've probably heard you know
people Orthodox people say beauty will
save the world it's almost become a
cliche that is not doesn't seem to mean
anything anymore but I but you have to
understand it in the right way yeah I
have to understand it in the sense that
that the the beauty if we have to
understand good as quality we have to
understand good as and so we if we only
understand good in terms of morality
we're missing out on an aspect of the
good in the sense of the incent and
scent in the sense of the high quality
of something and so you know a good you
know a a good a good microphone isn't a
moral question right it is it's a
highest quality of the purpose of the
essence of the microphone it's the
highest manifestation of the essence of
something and so the the the good in
that sense you know
the good of the world is that the
highest version the highest quality of
the of the manifestation of something
and so that's why beauty is related to
that right beauty is also a perception
of the quality of of a harmony in things
of a you know of this of this
manifestation of no because you can have
you can have music let's say but the
beauty and the music is is the capacity
for these things to truly come together
in this this kind of this kind of
powerful dance and so I totally
understand it sometimes I think some of
the plate is would say things like that
beauty is the expression of the good
something like that but the Dionysus
always is just bringing things to the
radical like you know when I said
recently I said that in a talk a lot of
people no notice when I said that
Christianity and Christianity the
expression of the infinite is equal to
the infinite you know it's like this is
Dionysus saying that kind of stuff it's
like the beautiful the same is the good
right the expression of the good in the
world is the same it's like when you
when you when you have that perception
of beauty then it's it's the same as the
good and obviously it's not the idea
that beauty is relative is just pure
nonsense is it's not relative and and
and the way that you can help people
understand it is that there's a that
there's a there are different desires
that we that we that we now confuse with
beauty and one is a kind of titillation
of the senses and so that is not beauty
there's a kind of titillation of the
senses that is is trying to grasp at
your desire your irascible nature you
know your desire to see novelty and so
we've actually right today we've
actually kind of confused
a sense or a perception of beauty with a
a kind of desire to to see new things
and to be to be titillated by new things
and so that is one of the reasons why a
lot of people are confused in beauty
because they see this new fashion and
they think well this fashion is gonna
come and it's gonna go and so that's the
proof that beauty is is vanity but it's
not because there are you could say that
beauty all it does tend to transcend
like and so it's there is a there is a
relative aspect to it but it's pointing
towards something so when we have the
experience of beauty we can see that in
the thing that we're looking at let's
say the beautiful church or a beautiful
painting we we have this sense that
there's a relationship between my
experience of looking at this beautiful
painting and looking at this beautiful
church there's something that's bringing
it together and that is what is kind of
leading you upwards and kind of leading
you up beyond you know the body of what
you're looking at you know and not to
deny the body of it but it's kind of
leading you off so so yeah I don't know
I mean the the the I think that one of
the arguments against the idea that the
tastes are that beauty is relative and
that it's all vanity or whatever is the
is the fact that when people started to
believe that in the modern age is when
ugliness started to abound and ugliness
that that pretty much everybody
recognizes you know the ugliness of this
suburban you know the suburban Road the
suburban there's this what there's few
streets here in Quebec and Laval
you know it's like you know these
horrible streets with all the wires and
then and then all these different
buildings with they still have these
light lighted signs and you know it's
all absolute chaos and the the gas
station and this and that like that is
just nobody
thinks that's beautiful there's just
nobody who thinks that's beautiful and
the only people who think that's
beautiful do it out a very concrete
sense of irony you know whether someone
like Andy Warhol and and that type they
they they they know that they're
participating in irony by engaging those
things with that with an like you would
engage things of beauty so anyways sorry
that's as much as I'm gonna savor about
that
alright so Craig Henrik's asks am i
understanding the connection between the
womb of the tomb correctly they both
represents potentiality possibility
correct yes the womb is where you unite
the egg and the seed legacy in flesh the
tomb is where you unite the son with the
father
saving the father from the underworld
and legacy of wisdom or better put the
union and update grade of the old with
the new I don't know I the whole guys
pushing me in directions I would be I
really have we really have to be careful
not to limit the symbolism of the tomb
to this this story that durin Peterson
tells about saving the father from the
underworld I have no problem with the
with the saving of the Father from the
underworld I think it's fine it's there
in Christianity as well by the way in
the resurrection the resurrection story
not it in that we don't see it in the
Bible but very soon after that the
tradition that Christ saved Adam out of
out of Hades it's exactly that it's
exactly saving your father from the
underworld but I think that both of
those are both of those are very much
the same so so sorry so you say like you
talked about the idea of unite the egg
and the seed all right and so the the
seed
the seed has to die just like it says in
Scripture the seed has to die before it
gives before it gives a new body right
and so the the the seed has to stop
being what it's from right now that's
how you have to understand the idea of
that of dying right and so in order for
there to be a new child the seed has to
stop being the father right it has to
not just be the father it has to be
something else and us has to die from
what it was and then that is what
creates that this union of heaven and
earth potentiality and and so the the
idea of the tomb is the same it's the
same thing at least in terms of at least
in terms of Christian thinking is that
when you you die and we put you in the
tomb then this is this this is also the
the seed it's it's sowing for the for a
resurrection it's sowing for a new a new
life now I don't you know I don't how
what exactly does that mean in terms of
in terms of how it's gonna play out it's
like I can't understand that I'm not I'm
here right I don't just like I can't
know what it was to be a sperm in my
father's body like I can't to be my
father I can't know that right and so I
can't also know what the next step is so
the idea that the womb and the tomb are
the place where where something stops to
be what it was and becomes something new
does that make sense I hope that makes
sense until both of them are really the
both of them are that are the same
now now in the in the the story of the
of uniting the son with the father in
the sense of going in to the underworld
to find your your father you can kind of
see it it's interesting because you can
you can kind of see it as it's kind of
like the reverse of the of cuz okay this
is this is tough because this is
difficult this is difficult and I'm
realizing how much this is how much is
complicated because the story of the
story of the hero that goes into two to
save his father in the underworld or to
encounter his father in the the
underworld it's not it's not the same
it's not the same father as let's say
the heavenly father and that's super
important because I think that's one of
the things that Jordan gets wrong
it's the dead father and the dead father
is not the same as the living father the
dead father is has sunken into
potentiality he's become in a way he's
becoming away an image also of the womb
in them in a way because he's he's just
these fragmented bits that you have to
go in and try to unite together in order
to make a new body out of and so but
it's not the same as your living father
and so the idea that God the Father
represents the same father as the as the
idea of the of the son that goes into
the womb - that goes into the tomb - -
to save his father is just not doesn't
make any sense it's not that at all
Christ does not go into Hades to save
God the Father that absolute doesn't
make sense God the Father also doesn't
represent the past in that sense in the
sense of the dead father God the Father
does not at all
represent that Adam represents that in
the story of Christ
Adam represents the dead father all
right but the dead father is this
broken-down potentiality too and so is
is the same kind of symbolism as the the
womb or the tomb I hope this makes sense
it's like in a way I should probably
make a video about this because I've
been thinking I've been I've been kind
of thinking about this for a while and
I've been thinking that I should
probably help clarify that problem you
know in terms of this idea of going into
the going into the to the to the to the
underworld to save your father so
anyways I hope that wasn't too
convoluted so Craig you because I like
you we got a really good conversation
the other day I will what I'll do is
I'll try to get my thoughts in line
properly and I will try to put out a
video it's Fliss Utley on that on the
question of the the the relationship
between the womb of the tomb the the
father the dead father and the living
father and to be able to differentiate
the two so so we'll do that all right so
thanks for question man all right so
Christian Chad who I think is not there
in the chat and makes me very sad to
know the Christian he's not there in the
chat it's like we don't have our epic
our epic man here alright so here we go
his question I've been seeing a
resurgence of interest and HP Lovecraft
especially on YouTube there's something
about the Cthulhu Mythos that I've that
I've been seeing in right-wing circles
online which I don't understand one
interesting video I found was labeled
horror is reactionary any comment on
this and you think the horror John is
symbol symbolically reactionary yeah I
agree I agree I agree that horror movies
are secretly conservative and I think
that's not that weird to say that
they're kind of secretly conservative
because horror movies this they disguise
this kind of horror this desire to see
horror and and in a kind of extreme
sometimes a lot of sexuality and all out
of
it's it's there as well I don't suggest
people watch horror movies but usually
most of the stories have a a kind of
divine punishment aspect to it you know
and they play with that like people have
noticed that obviously in the screen
movies they tried to kind of deconstruct
that narrative the idea that that and I
think also in the what was it that
recent horror movie the one that was
done by the the house in the woods or
something something like that I forget
what it's called anyways when they try
to deconstruct this story the idea that
that in fact usually horror movies have
a kind of fall punishment Redemption arc
in them where the whatever is happening
to the characters in the movie are a
result of some sin that has been that
has been done and it's kind of like the
revenge of the world on them and and and
some somehow in order to get out of it
it has to be done by some pure character
or some some act of reconciliation and
so and so yeah I think that's true I
think that there definitely is something
in there I don't know a lot about
Lovecraft I was never really interested
that much in his in his work so I know a
little bit about it but I haven't read
any I've only read like shorts things of
his alright so XRD says in one of your
videos from about a year ago you were
doing a walkthrough of an icon and use
the term divine darkness it's a term
that gets my mind burning anytime I
remember it it feels like it might be
something that requires a deep dive but
could you elaborate it on it some here
so the the image of divine darkness
usually usually the image of divine
darkness is is also related to it
there's a is usually presented as an
aporia they call it sometimes blinding
light in the sense that lights so bright
that you become blind that you can't see
anymore so it's like light and dark at
the same time so the idea is it is the
the aspect of God that we just that we
cannot grasp that is the aspect which is
beyond knowledge which is the
understanding you know it's the idea of
God as beyond being and if you watch a
few of my videos you'll see that I often
explain that God is beyond that there's
an apathetic move in Orthodox theology
which is to always understand that
whenever we say about God is all is
always lacking it never reaches to an
actual description of God we'd always
fall short because God is always beyond
everything and so that ends up taking on
the image of darkness because you can
imagine it's it's it's always beyond
whatever the light can show so usually
we refer to God's essence in that sense
as being this divine darkness but if you
read if you reading sanger of misa he
sees that in the divine darkness is the
mystery of the Incarnation itself
because he talks about that in the
devarnè darkness Moses sees the
tabernacle which is Christ himself
so the tabernacle becomes something
which is kind of like even beyond the
divine darkness because it is the union
of infinite and the unsayable the the
you know the non-dual aspect and duality
right and actual manifestation it's like
you know the ultimate blow your mind
thing where it's both unlimited and
limited at the same time now and I was
reading recently to I when we were
talking about how about Dionysius I was
recently reading some of his statements
man he just he has no he has no limit
you know he talks about God as being he
says God is beyond all name beyond being
and then he goes beyond the infinite and
I'm like dude you're really pushing it
that high you know it's like and beyond
even I think it even says Dion non-being
and it's like just you just any category
even non category you keep saying is
beyond that so alright alright guys so
I'm going now to patreon dude we already
been going for an hour and we got a lot
of questions to go I need to I need to
not be as a alright
okay so so John Barnes asked can you
comment on the work of Michael O'Brien I
don't know and you don't anything about
him
he says you commit a Canadian Roman
Catholic artist and novelist and student
of William cure like I haven't I've
never I'm specifically wondering when
you think of a Christian artist role as
a prophet and as a prophet of the end
times a central theme in O'Brien's
novels thank you for everything you're
doing with the symbolic world I mean I
think that Christian artists can play
role the role of a prophet and I I think
sometimes you'll be surprised to find
that non-christians will act as prophets
if you mean prophets depends what you
mean by prophet like if you if you mean
if you mean a prophet as someone who
kind of taps into the patterns and is
somehow able to describe things in a way
which is perceiving how the patterns are
playing themselves out you know in the
world today sometimes you get prophecy
from the strangest and most random
places that you know you hear a song in
the radio and you you realize that
you're listening to prophecy so but I do
think that Christians can play that role
I think that often they don't and I
think that often they do it very in a
very lousy manner but I like I can't
talk about the specific person's
writings but you know let's take the I'm
giving you the worst case scenario they
lick state let's take the Left Behind
series which was like you know prophecy
of the end times it just absolute crap
like just not just nope nothing no
insight on anything really just none not
very interesting at all so I have to
check him out and see if if what he's
doing is any good
all right so measurement would ask is
there significance to Eve not conceiving
up until after the initial fall is there
a place for procreation in the heavenly
City of the eschaton well that's an
interesting question
there's definitely significance in Eve
not conceiving until after the initial
fall because because conception and
sexual reproduction is a is the
consequence of the fall
and you know a lot of people today
somehow I want to deny that because they
think it you can it's like people can't
hold complex thoughts you can say that
there's nothing wrong with sexuality
that sexuality is is a good and also
understand that it is still a
consequence of the fall that it is also
a it is a the process of death playing
itself out no because you know you you
read and the father's about the idea
that human nature was broken into
individuals that that that human nature
was separated into a multitude of of
persons you know and then that is the
fall it's like this Paul just break and
this fragmentation you know and so and
so that's most most of the most of the
fathers that I read seem to explain it
that way some even go further than that
some say that that even the separation
of Adam into two people that Adam was
separated into Adam and Eve that was
already in in vision of the fall you
know and it's not silly to think that
because because Adam is put to sleep in
order to create Eve and so sleep is
really an image of death in all of
tradition and so there's this like
little death that God puts on Adam out
of which he separates Adam into two
people and so you can understand that
now there's something about that this
duality which it seems to already be
anticipating this fall into duality
which is going to come later
of course the creation Eve Eve is not a
fall of course not but it's like you can
see the process like the question is how
much how much fragmentation can you
handle how much do ality can you handle
until it starts until it splits and and
for sure
yeah for sure probe and you know if you
read in Scripture it really just says
that in there's the fall and then it
says Adam knew his wife you know it's
like okay well there's a relay there's a
reason why it says that right after the
fall and
and that conception and birth happens
afterwards so yeah
and is there place for procreation in
the heavenly City of the eschaton I
would probably say no I'd probably say
no but that's really I don't know if
I've ever read anything about that but I
would probably say no so John Barnes
asks can you know i already already said
that okay so drew mcmahon asked is it
possible to have standards for yourself
and those around you without judgment
Jesus teaches that only he can judge but
I find that the more that I confirm my
Christian identity beliefs the more I
feel myself judging others how do we
avoid this well there's really just one
way to avoid it is to just is to
constantly be looking back at yourself
and to constantly be asking yourself as
you the thing is the thing that's
interesting is that usually not always
but often the sins that we notice and
others our sins that we have sensitivity
to our self to ourselves that's why we
notice them and so the idea would be
that when you notice something in
someone else you would you the best way
to do it is that just let your eye turn
right back at you and try to notice why
you're noticing this sin and these other
people is it because you're tempted by
it is it because you're disgusted by it
and if you're disgusted by it what makes
you disgusted by other people's sins and
so it's like I would say to be able to
do that and but it should be absolutely
possible to have a high moral standard
and at the same time care for those who
don't dear to that standard you know we
do it all the time
and so so I think that's what you should
strive for yeah but there is something
that the problem that we're facing a
narrative which is the idea that if you
disagree with someone that means that
you if you disagree with someone's
position or someone's lifestyle you
somehow are judging the entire person
that's that if you think that like let's
say you know let's say that I let's say
that I I think it's funny because
a lot of it now is to do with with with
homosexuality it's like that seems to do
the big the big question you know
because some because Christians think
that it's it's a sin that somehow that
it means that we're judging the entire
person and that you hate the person
because of that it's like I have people
around me I have plenty of people around
me who are not married and living
together and have children and I think
that they should I think that that
ultimately that's how you should do it
you should be married you should have a
promise to the person you're with and
that's in that context that you should
have children and so I see the opposite
around me but it's just I hold that
standard but it doesn't mean that I
judge them and it doesn't mean that I
hate them or that I they're they're just
there and I can still be in
relationships with them and so to me
it's like it I don't think it's a I
don't think it's I don't know I don't
think it's that big of a deal yeah
alright but I understand the struggle
just because people there's such a weird
polemic today which which which which is
difficult to break from all right so
Taylor Wilson asked hello mr. Perot
thank you so much for your work I was a
bit confused about your concept of a
person what do you mean by person and
what makes a person a person it seems to
me that if you make any one thing which
is not a religious position the deciding
factor of what makes a person a person
you will inevitably create a greater or
lesser class of people such as racial
superiority the thing that the
rationalist types haven't yet realized
is that the concept of a person not a
human in the biological sense but the
sense of being made in the image of God
see now I think that that's the problem
I think that this is the problem I think
this is maybe the the issue is like
there's no place where it says that a
person is created in the image of God I
don't know where you saw that a man is
created in the image of God and so a
person is a is an is an actual it's a is
a is a incarnation of human nature it's
a it's an it's an actual human
it's a human in the world right that's
it's a bit some so it's not and so the
idea and the Christian understanding is
a person the word person comes from the
notion of hypostasis that is it's a
particular thing so there's a there's a
hypo stassi's of microphone there's a
hypo stassi's of every essence has
different manifestations so you have
book but you have the that notion of a
book and then you have books books are
high posts are hyper statuses of a book
now we use the word person in a very
specific sense today in a kind of moral
sense in all of that you know and that's
fine but we need to understand that the
person is an instantiation of man is a
is a is an is a child of Adam that's
what makes a person a person a person is
being a an instantiation of human nature
alright okay so that's important but
when when but if you also don't
understand that there's an analogy
between that and the notion of
hypostasis then you will never
understand what it means what would we
say that God is three persons what we're
talking about because God is not a man
God is not a man I mean Christ
incarnated into and divinized human
nature but you know God the Father is
not a man right the human the divine
essence and the human nature are not the
same so it's just a different like it's
just really a different way to
understand things I don't know I don't
know all right okay so it's alright
sorry man so so he says that the thing
that ration types haven't yet realized
is that the content of a person not a
human the violence besides but in the
sense of being made demon of God is
completely rational
from the scientific perspective people
are different across every discernible
dimension so yeah
so that's it there's a human nature and
there are there are instantiation of
that nature there are actual humans and
we that's it
like that's what a person is in the
sense of a human person that's what
that's what that's what a person is so I
don't know that that's that's yeah yeah
I hope that makes sense it's just it is
a different way of thinking and I know
people aren't used to thinking that way
but it if you're able to start thinking
that way it's gonna solve a lot of
problems for you you know because yeah
alright okay so nor Norman a asks you've
all Noah Harare wrote humanism is the
belief that all knowledge comes from the
self based upon how we feel rather than
from the sky from the divine what do you
think of the humanism idea that we as
humans are to create our own meaning now
yeah I think it's nonsense does it make
him it doesn't make any sense does it
doesn't mean if you think it's like the
belief that all knowledge comes from the
self based on how we feel rather than
from the sky from the divine that's I
mean I don't know I don't know what that
person means it it's absolute nonsense
that uh the fact that drinking water
makes you live
that's meaning that doesn't come from
the self it doesn't come from your
feelings the the the fact that the fact
that if that if something is too low in
your house you're gonna bump your head
against it that doesn't come from the
self right and that that's also part of
understanding meaning they're there and
and there's a there's such a problem
with that type of thinking there's such
a problem because where does that come
from where do what we feel come from
like where does what we where does the
self with the self is this the supremely
unique thing in the entire universe and
so it's like there's there's all this
stuff and then there's the self and
there's somehow there's no relationship
between all this stuff and the self
there's no relationship between I don't
know there's just that to me humanism
doesn't make a lot of a lot of a lot of
sense and at all you can't create your
own meaning just doesn't work you know I
mean you can try you can you can pretend
that you're doing it but there are
certain there's certain normal they're
search of natural hierarchies in the
world which are just are just functional
and if you try to create your own
meaning at some point you're gonna start
bumping up against probably against
reality
and I mean reality I just don't mean
just just mean the physical reality but
just the pattern reality of the world
you're just gonna start bumping up
against it and it's not gonna work and
you see that you just see that in a lot
of ideological thinking and a lot of I
see it in a lot of weird kind of utopian
ideas where they they they they don't
because they don't understand the
patterns they think that they can just
design something and create their own
meaning but they don't because they
don't understand the actual meaning in
the universe and the actual patterns
they can't see the unforeseen
consequences of their actions and then
they're surprised when it comes and
kicks
in the ass you know they're surprised
that when it happens it's like you know
it's the same problem with like Steven
Pinker who who just wants to take
everything he doesn't like about the
modern world and call it the counter
enlightenment if it's not it's not
they're not manifestations of the same
process and the same thinking that
creates the things he likes about the
modern world it's just you can't it
doesn't work that way it's gonna come
back and kick you if you don't if you
don't take it into account all right ok
so Alisa Bruggeman asks I've been
thinking about your discussion about
Frankenstein and golems in one of the
previous videos it occurred to me that
those types of monsters are men trying
to procreate on their own perhaps it's a
warning that procreation that is not the
result of the union of the two sexes
creates the monster the resulting
offspring can be fully formed or have a
soul if it's not the consequence of Kent
sorry the resulting offspring can't be
fully formed or have a soul if it's not
the consequence of the joining of man
and woman I'm on the right track with
that track with that thank you for so
much for your discussions um you can
understand it that way to a certain
extent in the sense of this idea of
creating an artificial being there's
definitely something there's definitely
something about that especially
Frankenstein in the golem and you you
can understand it you know what do I was
just talking about before right what
would I what I was just talking about
before the idea that you think that you
get it you can completely impose your
will upon nature in the sense of the
creation and that you can you can create
something which is going to be an image
of you and is going to be fully like
that is going to fully respond in the
way that you think it's going to respond
you know and that that pride the pride
that you think you can do that means
that you are lacking the insight to to
see how reality actually works and so
that thing you're going to create is
going to have a backlash to it it's
going to have a a side effect to
that you're not going to you're not
gonna know until you you in enact it and
then it's gonna come back you know and
you see that especially in the golem you
see that of course but I think that
that's the people who were talking about
a I should really read the golem because
you know that's what that's what
happened with the golem and it's not
it's gonna happen with a I it's as the
AI is gonna be a hope of the world it's
not just gonna be in Prague alright
alright so Julie P asks will you explain
what happened in the 11th or 12th
century and why was it pivotal moment in
western thinking uh yeah I mentioned
that in the last Q&A thanks Lisa
she added a comment I think probably be
better to go there and check it out just
because it's been I still have a lot of
questions to answer and so I think I'm
just gonna keep going with that one so
check out the comment last Q&A at minute
5813 to see me talk about the eleven
twelve century and what happened there
so Lisa parent asks what's the symbolism
of tattoos it really is it related to
graffiti throwback to all the graffiti
in the Joker movie I guess it's a form
of ornamentation tries to fix an
identity yeah why do we generally
associate tattoos with rebellion
irrespective of the explicit message of
the tattoo it's also interesting to me
that they're quite permanent and yet
people sometimes get addicted to getting
new ones reminds you of how social media
works in the sense that we're always
chasing novelty while simultaneously
building up a permanent record of who we
are and want to be yeah I think your
insight is dead-on right there I think
that your insight about graffiti is very
good I think your insight about social
media is also very good in the sense of
of creating these these additions to
your identity these extensions of your
identity which are not fully thought out
and and and are somehow manifest the the
tattoos often end up manifest
some demon like or some some some
passion or some some thing about that
person that they that they have to
exteriorize you know the people who have
these weird like really strong desires
to get a tattoo of some thing some
random thing and so and so that's kind
of how I feel it's kind of like a
celebration of the accidental and the
random and in a way that has to do with
graffiti and so in that sense that's
that's why it's related to rebellion as
well this idea of kind of
self-expression the ultimate version of
self-expression you could say is
graffiti and tattoo and it's such a
caricature that you can you can end up
seeing how a kind of silly it is and and
how it actually lacks a lot of it lacks
profundity like I don't have any
problems with tattoos you know it's like
i think i think it's fines you want to
get a tattoo there are some tattoos for
example like the idea of caught the
christians who gets tattooed crosses on
themselves in order to remember their
christianity i think you know they're
they're useful possibilities for tattoos
but i think a lot of a lot of modern
tattoos have to do with this weird
excess of ornamentation that you
mentioned and also a kind of reign of
the arbitrary you know kind of latching
on to the arbitrary so Laura jules asked
you have said in your recent video
discussion with Benjamin Voice which I
love that the modern world is too
masculine isn't the US and other
Protestant based cultures more likely to
be that way because of the fact that
they don't honor the place an example of
the Theotokos and of Mary I think it's
true I think that for sure I think that
there's a relationship between the
putting aside of the reverence to Mary
in in the West and the rise of extreme
rationalism and and kind of scientific
culture or scientism I think there's
definitely a relationship in that it's
as if in in
the denier in the desire to deny the the
body that received the logos they it's
like they they didn't have a way to
compensate that with something else and
so yeah yeah I think I think that for
sure and this idea also that the that
the earth became just a just a kind of
storehouse for four things you know and
didn't have a sacred aspect to it or
something that we needed to be careful
of and be respectful of I think is also
is also there and so in this idea of
abusing ecology or you know or stripping
resources and and all this type of stuff
has to do with a hyper masculine hyper
masculine aspect of the world so what
does Christ mean when he says truly I
tell you unless you change and become
like little children
you'll never enter the kingdom of heaven
I mean I think that that sense as has
many many meanings it's a very profound
one one of the ways that maybe I can
relate you to this based on my recent
video on on hierarchy and inversion and
everything is the idea that the child is
a completely dependent on their parents
and I think that that's what that means
is that when we talk about freedom we
have this strange idea of freedom we
have the idea that we kind of become our
own self-contained thing that we are
that we are you know just
self-sufficient but that is definitely
not the Christian way of understanding
things like yes you have to be
responsible yes you have to free
yourselves from your passions yes you
have to to do all those things but you
have to do it as you are fully
submitting yourself to that which is
above you and so that is what it means
to become like a child in the sense that
you are completely dependent completely
submitted you know and and and when you
send a child it's really a babe you know
like
like a little baby that can't do
anything without their parents and so
and I know that this is this this is
gonna sound weird for people but that's
in a way that is ultimately how we're
supposed to live that we that we become
responsible for that which is below us
that we that we it doesn't mean that
we're that we are passive or that we
don't engage with the world but it means
that as to the things which are above us
we are completely given to those and
then as to the things which are below us
which is which are in our kingdom to
rule or to or to engage with then those
things we have to be fully engaged with
in terms of being responsible in terms
of being active in terms of doing the
things we need to do so to me that's
what I think that's what that's one of
the things that I think Christ is
talking about in terms of to be like
children um and there's also has to do
with being small there's a lot of
symbolism the Christ's use in terms of
this idea of becoming small you know
this idea of the seed you know the seed
that is small that the smallest seed of
all that gives the biggest tree and this
idea of becoming small in the sense of
also removing all your externals all the
things that you've accumulated to kind
of remove them to strip them as you
enter into the essence of what you are
as you enter into your heart as you
enter into that and I think that that's
also one of the things that Christ is
referring to when he talks about
becoming like a child so Benjamin would
ask one of the most interesting bits I
got from ochio goss's talked on the book
a billion wicked thoughts which attempts
to survey the patterns in doing
pornography is the popularity of
transgender porn among straight male
viewers in a conversation with Peterson
you discussed the desirability of the
monstrous things that merge or defy
categories and its relation to JB P's
point about monkeys fixating on a snake
is the fixation of the trans issue
whether in abstract political notions or
sexual fetishes fetishization a
manifestation of this what does the
healthy relationship to the monsters
look like yeah I think it definitely is
a manifestation of this the the
you guys forced me to talk about stuff
that's gonna get me in trouble
seriously the the the idea that the
monstrous or the undefined is the
undefined can be a source of seduction
because it's undefined it's asking to be
it wants it you know it's luring you in
by the question by the mystery by the
the strangeness by the by the surprise
by the by the unknown right and so it's
not it's not surprising that people as
they as they they get into the world of
pornography where it's like it is
entering into this world of increase of
of stimulation increase of curiosity
increase of a possibility that at some
point they're going to go in that
direction because it's the ultimate
place where all the categories merge and
all the all the strangeness manifests
itself you know there's actually a
there's actually an interesting essay
that shambhu dayal wrote about that
where he talks about that the the I
think he was talking more about the
crossdresser in his in his text but it
still fits and in the sense that there's
a there's a sense where it's it's like a
it's pure desire it becomes pure desire
because the whole aspect of that the
whole aspect of procreation is
completely gone
it becomes only about about sexuality
right it's like it can only be about
that and it and it joins the two aspects
together into one figure to gaze upon
and so the the fact that it kind of it
kind of confuses and merges all these
things which is what desire does already
and and the fact that that there's no
life there there's no joining of
masculine feminine in
it's okay here's the way to understand
it if it's it's the opposite of joining
of masculine and feminine it's the
confusion of masculine and feminine and
so it's like the opposite of an actual
relationship so that character is that
is the mere reflection of the other and
so it's normal that is as you go down
into that dark place that is what you're
going to end up at some point becoming
you know at least in your in your
fantasies it's what's going to kind of
inhabit your fantasies I'm not that
surprising not that surprised to to to
to to know that you know and so what
does a healthy relationship to the
monstrous look like most monsters just
have to be left alone that's usually
what monsters that's usually the most
healthy relationship to Monster is to
just to just leave it and to not to not
deal with it to just to just leave it in
the margin as long as it stays in the
margin just not all right that's as good
as I'm gonna get on that guy's so now
I'm gonna see I'm not surprised I'm
gonna see all these message all these
things in the chat that are being held
held because of this subject guys I
probably should have skipped that
question all right okay here we go
all right so father all right so father
Scott Murray to the Orthodox allowed
cremation any thoughts on the symbolism
of a funeral and the presence of ashes
versus a funeral in the presence of the
body have a blessed Christmas an
epiphany and add to my understanding
Orthodox do not allow cremation I'm sure
that that it has happened in the most
extreme cases but I think that that the
Orthodox always encouraged Bureau Muriel
and I and I mean these the symbolism of
death and burial is difficult to fully
understand in the sense of why did why
would it be important to bury the body I
think it's important in terms of
symbolism in our participation in
symbolism this idea of of to say of to
see the body and to see the body go into
the earth I think there's something
about all of that which is all of that
which is happening
which is extremely important in terms of
us participating in deaf that's as good
as it's gonna get very Kevin asked what
is the symbolism of the two witnesses in
Revelations dude I don't know man I
don't know I I I don't want to go into
revelations it's that's tough stuff
that's tough stuff I mean traditionally
the two witnesses have been understood
to be to be Enoch and Elijah the two
that were taken up you know I've seen
that in in I forget which texts that I
saw which with which interpretation I
saw that in yeah sorry man I'm not gonna
go far on that one right so similar
bears asks in French bonsoir mocha leg
the Catechism is Julian Sandiford
supposes that Castillo he says his his
his colleague in catechism was asking
himself this question what is the
meaning of the wheels within wheels in
Ezekiel's vision and more specifically
of the eyes surrounding the wheels Mexia
levels and so I the way that I
understand the wheels within wheels is
really he's seeing a pattern of reality
he's really he's really seeing these
that he's really seeing this fractal
structure that I'm talking about so it's
like it's like a wheel within a wheel
than a wheel within a wheel right so
it's the same structure as it gets
bigger that's the way I see it and and I
think the idea that they're covered in
eyes it means that it's their patterns
of knowledge their patterns of
consciousness you could say today that
there that there that there are patterns
that know the world and that are to be
known right there they're the element of
knowing in the world so there are the
structures they're the structures of
reality that to me that's the best way
of understanding it so Roberts minutes
asked the recent Gospel was the axe at
the root of the tree looking to sin
Ephraim what are your thoughts on the
lid
being symbolic of cutting down trees
which hide the Tree of Life after all we
begin with confession absolution which
undoes the thorns then the reading of
the true word which undoes the fig
leaves which are symbolic for the words
of the world finally communion in an
undoing of the tree of knowledge of good
and evil as Christ is not only the new
Adam but the new Apple as it were I
agree with you to a certain extent and I
think it's ok to see it that way I think
it's all it's always ok to see this
moving into the center as a removal of
the garments of skin as a cutting off of
the of the of the outside and moving in
towards the trunk of the tree you could
say but you all you have to understand
that once you get to the middle once you
get to the Tree of Life then everything
else comes with it it's it's never fully
a denial so there's a denial of let's
say the thorns and the and the fig leaf
and all of this and the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil if you read
Saint Ephrem he says that that the way
that God wanted for Adam and Eve was to
to eat the Tree of Life and then eat the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
in the sense that that which is above
contains that which is below ultimately
and so that's why Christ whereas a crown
of thorns I've talked about that a
million times before
and so and so yes but at the same time
everything is gathered into into
communion right and that's why communion
is like I've talked about again before
that's why communion isn't just just the
apple right
communion isn't communion also contains
the scandal in it right it is the eating
of flesh and blood it contained the
scandal within its transcending of all
of it and so it has everything inside of
it all right ok so there you go we got
through all the questions and so now
gonna go into the soup chats
all right let's see this these Q&A is
becoming really long guys to find some
kind of uh some kind of a solution to
that because I'm not and that they used
to all right there and I heard so many
all right so Virginia Charlotte asks can
men on the the mug how do you river that
mgtow McDow mgt o w path created enough
feminine space to adequately frame and
nurture their masculine quest needs who
will care for an aging solitary man's
needs when he no longer can no longer do
it alone I think I've ever talked about
this whole this whole this this whole
thing in the world to be honest I don't
know a lot about it I think that I think
that I don't know what people's I mean I
kind of I can understand the motivations
of people who go down that path I would
say that for people for men who want to
go down that path the best way to go the
true way to go down that path for it to
have some kind of positive effect on you
would be to become a monk dude did too
to do it go all out like go become
become a monk leaving us live an ascetic
lifestyle you know if you want your if
you want your let's say suffering to
become something more but if someone
does kind of decide to go down that path
out of bitterness and remains better and
then lives a life of like you know
solitary masturbation for the rest of
their life and you know watching porn in
and saying that they want nothing to do
with women it's like I don't see how
that is going to I don't see how that is
going to help you become a better person
I mean I could like I said I can
understand how crazy the world has
become and how nuts
some of the the things that I've seen I
know people I know guys who have been
absolutely demolished by you know crazy
women who had their children and that
completely destroyed them and it's like
man that's enough stuff you know and
legal systems on their side and
everything is against you you know I can
I can totally understand that but still
I have to say that I think that for our
own salvation I would say that yeah I
would say it's like either become a monk
and go all out and use that suffering
for transcendence or you have to somehow
reconcile yourself with that and then
and then not you know not not live in
bitterness you know but I don't know I
don't know I don't know each person is
different and maybe maybe I am putting
I'm putting intentions and people that
are not there maybe men are able to live
without bitterness and to go on their
own and to live to live solitary lives I
think that's probably totally possible
but anyways I'd become a monk that's
what I do but it's like I mean you know
I have a great my wife is great and my
kids are great and my family is
wonderful one of the things too is like
I you know I I hate to say this to you
guys but you know depends where you also
find your the women that you guys are
burying you know you if you meet a girl
in a bar that has you know look I go to
church you go to church how many times
have to tell you guys if you want to
find a woman go to church the best place
to find a woman all right it's not a
hundred percent you know just like guys
in church and I don't percent either but
you your average the average possibility
of finding someone who who will want to
live and make put the effort in and and
live well at least good
get higher if you go to church all right
sorry I don't want to make it sound like
I you know that I did no sympathy here
okay so patch higher says upside-down
pyramids fall sideways how can we tell
if an inverted hierarchy reverts
properly how can we tell if an inverted
hierarchy reverts properly I mean just
the only way you can tell is that it
just becomes a normal hierarchy a normal
hierarchy is has qualities you can
recognize them they they whenever the
hierarchy is for in terms it can be any
type of hierarchy it can be like it to
be a spiritual hierarchy it can be
hierarchy of the best plumber or the
hierarchy of the of you know whatever
lower hierarchy in a business or
whatever the the way that you know that
a hierarchy is working properly is that
the person that is the people that are
atop the hierarchy are serving the
purpose of the hierarchy and that that
the people that are below the hierarchy
are given ways to engage with the
hierarchy in a manner which is
appropriate to their level at each level
of the the hierarchy and that there is
also a manner in which you can recognize
what is inside and what is outside and
what is in the buffer zone you could say
I guess that would that would be the
that would be the way this to tell I
think all right all right okay okay so
they
trails ass don't want you to betray any
confidence but have you talked to jbp
lately how's he doing and you ever
discussed matters of faith them I got a
message from him yesterday and he's
still not doing great he's still he's
still still struggling I think he's back
in Toronto but I to be honest I haven't
had a lot of contact with him for the
past year
you know just small notes small emails
like he's still he still writes me
little notes and I'll still write him
little notes but we haven't had any any
long discussion
I just finished a carving for him which
I'm going to hopefully deliver to him in
January and I'm hoping it'll be a chance
for me to actually talk to him just cuz
like I said I haven't talked to him
forever
Ivan Ivan actually had a conversation
with him for more than like a year Oh
more than a year yeah more than a year
all right
so Baron von Blair says for five dollars
thank you for being part of my
edification my pleasure Michael Griffin
50 dollars and no questions dude
thank you that's awesome Jonathan aught
says for five dollars in what capacity
do the 12 apostles judge the 12 tribes
of Israel where do they judge the 12
tribes of Israel I think a way to
understand the 12 apostles in
relationship to the twelve tribes of
Israel is to understand them as being
that you know that the entering into
that individual right the entering into
the the persons and that's what also
Christ does it's like you can see God
kind of manifesting himself descending
the hierarchy in one of those steps in
order to encounter us one of those steps
is the the nation and then it comes down
to the personal and then that's that's
the incarnation of Christ and then the
disciples become you know become like
Israel in the personal realm they become
principalities I don't know about
judging the twelve tribes of Israel but
this idea that they will judge the world
with Christ is really important to
understand in the sense that that Christ
is has his body right and so it's like
the disciples will judge the world with
Christ and then ultimately you can
understand it you couldn't understand it
as the whole body of Christ will judge
the world with Christ you know you in a
different levels you could say it like
that
okay so Jonathan ought four or five
dollars and modern conspiracy theories
aside do you think scripture says that
there will be a physical third temple I
don't know I don't think so I don't
think scripture says that you mean that
like the vision of the vision of Ezekiel
and I think that's like a really an
eschatological description in Ezekiel I
think so Nick sermon to five dollars
asks thoughts regarding Q and on dude
Cuban I haven't really looked into Q not
enough to answering this question
it is like the canary in the coal mine
secret leader sending codes to save the
Republic white hat scenario I mean I
don't I don't have I think I've answered
about Q and on I haven't really followed
it very much what I've seen of Q non is
that it seems to be hit miss you know
and it seems to be someone using obscure
languages for reason it's not quite
clear why you know kind of like
Nostradamus I don't know I don't I don't
know I haven't really followed it um AHA
satva asks what do you know about from A
to E and what do you think about it
I mean and you guys asking these
questions I think I think Freemasonry
seems to have seems to have genuine
interesting roots seems to some of the
symbolism that I've seen in Freemasonry
seem to be interesting and I'm not
talking about like the conspiracy
version like the the you know the Leo
Taxil
idea that they worship Baphomet or
whatever when you'll actually look at
their traditions there's some
interesting things there but like I said
in other videos I think that what's
happened with Freemasonry it seems that
that if they it's true and that
according to the tradition they come
from this line of builders and this line
of Cathedral builders you know that have
some understanding of patterns in terms
of architecture and how those those
analogies refer to actually the actual
shape of the cosmos there seems to be
some interesting things there but what
seems to have happened is that they it
seems to have been become a place of
subversion you know and if you look at a
lot of the subversive movements and the
modern world seems to they seem to be
related to - to Freemasonry and some of
it is has to do with also a weird thing
in Protestantism like it somehow got
connected to Protestantism and that
there was also a connection with a with
with Jacques de Molay and the Templars
and this idea that there had it to be a
revenge against the Catholic Church um
like all of that seems to be in there
and so so I'm I you know I think there
are reasons why the catholic church and
the orthodox church and the traditional
churches have condemned Freemasonry
because they saw that there is a
relationship between they could see that
the Freemasons were involved in the
revolutionary movements that the
Freemasons were involved in in in a lot
of the things that we're going on now it
doesn't mean that all of their symbolism
is is necessarily bunk just like I think
that prosit ISM is problematic but I
don't think that all their symbolism is
about neither you know and and I think
that you know I'm back I'm not a fan of
Hinduism and I'm not I'm a Christian but
I can look at Hinduism and find some
interesting things in Hinduism as well
and so there are some like there's some
interesting aspects in Freemasonry about
the idea of the cut stone and the uncut
stone and so you can see the two sides
know the the right hand and the left
hand
so there's some interesting stuff but I
really haven't
I didn't haven't felt the need to look
at it very much because I'm a Christian
and I'm an Orthodox Christian and the
Orthodox Church doesn't allow you to be
a freemason and so to me that's enough
like I don't I don't feel the need to
really dive into it and find out about
it and know all its symbolism but the
times where I have met some Freemasons
and they've kind of explained some of it
to me some of it seemed interesting but
uh yeah that's all I can say um so they
do it online for $5 asked me they are
mmo's an example of an attempting to
recreate communal participatory ritual
that we lack in modern culture I don't
know what's ahem mo I don't know what
that is
Oh what is it Oh massively multiplayer
online games ok that's what it is it
shows you guys how not a gamer I am no I
think you're right I totally agree I
think there are examples there an
attempt to to do that and I'm not saying
they can't play a role in sparking
something in someone that kind of desire
to to live out adventure like any any of
these types of these types of peripheral
things I think that they can maybe act
as a as a as a way to wake someone up
and and want them and I can see it like
you can see it in gamergate you can see
in gamergate
there's some interesting things that
have come out of it in terms of people
thinking for themselves and people
trying to explore different you know
it's like Sargon of Akkad came out of
gamergate like I don't agree with
everything Sargon of Akkad says but I
mean he's obviously at least trying to
think about things and he's trying to
kind of figure things out and so you
know it's possible that it could be a
gateway to help to people wanting to
engage in the world but it can also do
the opposite that is for sure I think
people can get lost in those things and
it can be a way to escape your life so
alright let me just
refresh this and then I think we're
gonna be done guys cuz alright so I've
got two more and then that's it so I'm
gonna do two more and then we're done
so panic us two rows for five dollars
says hi Jonathan hope you and your
family have a blessed Nativity also can
you give us an update on Matthew's new
book on Prophet David so I don't know I
don't know I I'm gonna see Matt's here
and during the holiday season he doesn't
have a phone now he doesn't have the
internet and so I have no way of
contacting him barely once in a while
he'll write a message I think he I think
he's like borrowing someone's phone or
whatever so I don't know so I'll ask him
when I see him in around the holidays
alright so lessons for life - two - two
pounds says recently visited Syria and
saw a lot of monasteries all right well
it's good to know thanks guys
alright so I want to say thank you to
everybody for coming in and I don't know
who ended up moderating I hope - what
was moderating because with all those
questions about Freemasonry and stuff it
must have been crazy in the chat guys
and hopefully hopefully everything is
gonna be okay
so so yeah so guys thank you for your
time and and I will see all of you see
all of you next month alright bye bye
guys